[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to the final
game we'll be showing uh from the
finals between tamura java and lebanon
this is game two we've already seen what
happened in game one after all that
craziness on both parts of the game
ended in a draw our trouble had a bit of
a better position but uh he didn't have
time to find the viable plan so they
just kept repeating moves
and now this is game two uh rajabov has
the white pieces and now uh we'll see
what happens here so rechable opens with
d4 we have knight to f6 c4 we have g6
knights to c3 and here 11 goes for d5 he
goes for the groomfield defense
and rajava avoids the main line and goes
for bishop to g5 this is the stockholm
variation of the groomfield
and it's it's a bit different but it's
also been played quite a lot so knight
the e4 now offering to trade knights and
attacking the bishop here and now rajabo
just brings back the bishop bishop to f4
knight captures on c3 with b captures
and now
c5 striking in the center and now there
are a few games in the database where
this position has been reached where
knight to f3 was played
but here we have e3 better job of and it
is as of move 7 that we have a
completely new game
so 11 continues developing pieces knight
to c6
and now uh c captures and e5 we have
queen captures on d5
and now it seems like it might be a good
idea to kick back the queen let's say c
for d5 always uh
great to grab more space in the center
but here it doesn't really work
because after c4 black's gonna play
queen d8 and now
black is threatening to trade here in
the center and also get a very nice
position and
if you push d5 then queen to a5 check
and white doesn't really have anything
awesome to show for it
you either have to trade queens or or
move the king
so instead uh queen to f3 right away
white uh
offers a queen trade this way and 11
declines queen to d7
uh we have bishop to b5 now pinning the
knight threatening d5 to win material
so a6 attacking the bishop captures
captures and hear a job of trades with
queen captures in c6b captures and c6
and now
rojobo just continues developing knight
to f3 and
uh he's he's very happy with his
position not just in this game but also
uh in the entire match with bishop to g7
and now uh knights to e5 putting
pressure on that c6 pawn but levin says
it's not a problem you can have it he
just plays bishop to f5
and now of course if you grab the pawn
then you run into bishop to e4 you can
even trade once captures captures and
bishop to e4 and you get a nice double
attack here
so nothing nothing great here for white
so instead f3
just takes away these two squares bishop
to e4 will not be possible now
and uh here you either have to defend
the c6 pawn or eliminate the attacker of
the
c6 pawn so bishop characters is played
bishop captures attacking the rook and
now
f6 pushing that bishop back bishop to g3
and now bishop to d3 not allowing white
to castle
and also black might have some ideas of
pushing c4
as black does have doubled pawn so
you're gonna push c4 defend your bishop
and then push the other pawn to c5 and
hopefully trade in the center
so rook to d1 attacking the bishop and
now c4 so the white king is not
or really trapped he can still play king
of two you can bring the other rook into
the game so it's not all that terrible
uh but he's gonna have to uh find some
some nice
moves to get out of there so rook to d2
he cannot go rook to b1 the bishop
covers that so he needs to go here
uh to control this file and now k2f7 11
connects his rooks we have rook to b2
now grabbing hold of the b file and now
rook
h to d8 uh just getting that rook in
with ideas of maybe rook to d5 you can
bring the rook to b5 maybe you can
undouble your pawns this way
so e4 creating a massive uh
pawn uh chain in the center here and now
c5 like we said at some point
you will want to trade off one of those
doubled pawns and here
uh rajav said okay that's a very
interesting move
and i might have to double my own pawns
to react to this but i'm gonna capture
it because it's a free pawn
and this is maybe one one pawn too many
that uh
11 gave rajab of as uh he's not going to
be able to win it back all that easy he
plays rook 8 to c8
and now bishop to f2 rajava defends it
and um
well you didn't really gain all that
much by by that pawn sacrifice
but 11 is in such a position in the
match that he has to create these
little imbalances in the position where
he can hope to
maybe achieve something uh but it's very
hard uh
to do against uh against a player like
rajabo so here
f5 and now he's asking what do you want
to do i'm threatening to win
a pawn here by captures captures and of
course captures
uh so what do you do here uh we have
captures by rajab of g
captures on f5 and now bishop to e3
uh so again what do you do here uh here
the pawn is nicely protected and black
has no good ways of entering the
position so levin finds a way as
he always does he plays f4 and now
either forces the the bishop back
or he forces a trade here captures with
captures and rajab says
okay it's a doubled pawn you may have it
so bishop captures
a rook captures and now king to f2 now
rajab is bringing the king
the rook into the game uh with rook to
b5 now offering a queen trade
uh sorry a rook trade and here you
really have to figure out what to do
here
i mean black does have a fine grip on
the position with this
c4 bishop to d3 idea and if he doubles
rooks here it's going to be it's going
to be pretty scary if you move the rook
away from the b
file what do you play do you play some
like rook to d2 doesn't really look like
a very active move
and capturing here will kind of allow
black to use the a file but this is
exactly what
rajab plays and uh it's very nice to see
that such
such fine moves are uh found over the
board in
in rapid time format so we'll capture
spawn captures and
now a3 a3 is a wonderful pawn move
uh because it prevents black from
pushing this pawn anytime soon and also
it allows the bishop to c1 to defend the
a3 pawn so rook coming to a8
will not be all that big of a deal uh he
tries it rook to a8 but now
uh not bishop to c1 right away first
rajab goes
rook to a1 so he prefers to defend it
this way
uh with rook to a6 and now g4
now rojaba will start expanding his
pawns on the king's side king to e6
and now h4 we have king to d5
and now even h5 and now e5 by 11.
we bishop back to e3 and now rook back
to a8 and now
bishop back to g5 king to e6
and now bishop to h4 11 is very happy
repeating king b5
uh with king to e6 as he says okay rajab
will you find a way to push for a win
here
europe upon your position is better but
i i
i i will try to hold this so king to e3
and now king back to e6 and here rook to
a2
we have king back to d5 and now bishop
to e7
shifting the bishop over to b4 with king
to e6
bishop to b4 and now something
incredible happened
all of a sudden 11 stopped repeating
moves but instead he played h6 and this
is a very weird move to play
uh since uh white has a dark square
bishop and you just put your pawn on a
dark square and this is a long-term
weakness
and it's uh well it's definitely
something rajab can play against
because up until this point he was just
you know
moving around trying to find the
weakness but now
uh lemon actually gives him a a a real
weakness to hone in on
so here rook back to b2 now rajab says
okay now we're gonna
create two weaknesses there's the
weakness and there's the weakness so
let's see if you can defend both
uh bishop back to h7 king to f2 and here
bishop back to d3 11 very happy
repeating the position
bishop to c5 now now you're going to go
here attack the pawn as it's on a dark
square the rook attacks this pawn
so one of those pawns will fall
and here if you go rook to b8 to defend
the pawn like this then just bishop to
e3 and like i said you cannot defend
both of them so instead
king to d5 attacking the bishop and now
of course if you capture here
uh it's not really great king c6 will
win you some material
so instead king d5 we have bishop back
to e3
now both of the pawns are under attack
uh
and here we have king to c6 defending
the pawn
here you could also consider rook
captures an a3 maybe that was
uh maybe that was an option for eleven
but he prefers to
defend the b5 pawn and now he was hoping
for bishop captures and then he's going
to capture on a3
but rajavo doesn't even allow that he
plays rook to a2
and now what do you play here uh if you
go
defending with rook to h8 then just a4
and
white breaks through here captures
captures and now
you're not gonna really be defending
that pawn for example if this comes
you're gonna get
get a nice check here and there's really
no good way to
to deal with this the rook is coming
into the game anyway
if you're trying to block it with the
king you can even go rook to a7 check
then bring the rook over to the king
side
uh a lot of possibilities here so 11
says okay
you can have that pawn i'm going to play
e4 here and i'm going all out either
either i win or i don't so here e4
and rajabo finally grabs the pawn bishop
captures an h6 with e captures on f3
king captures an f3 and now even b4
so of course the pawn cannot capture
because the rook captures rook
so c captures on b3 and now c3
11 is down three pawns but he's pushing
this pawn
uh as fast as he can so king e3
and now comes bishop back to b1
attacking your javascript
rook to a1 and now even c2 threatening
c1 queen
as the the king is blocking the bishop's
path so you have to move the king king
f3
now the bishop guards the c1 square and
here king to b5 he defends
and it's uh very very difficult to find
a move here for
white let alone a winning move for a job
of but
that's exactly what you need to do here
so feel free to pause the video
and try to find a winning move for a job
of here while i give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting the
move that was
almost unspottable and for those who
just want to enjoy the show it's a for
check looks like a weird move to play
because the a4 square is defended twice
by black but that's exactly the only
move that wins the game
uh because the problem is you can never
capture with the rook if you capture
with the rook then captures and captures
and then
uh well these two pawns are just winning
you're gonna move your bishop and push
those pawns to victory
remember white is up two pawns and even
if king captures on b4 you're going to
play h6 bishop to a2
guard the dis guard this square but it
doesn't help you all that much
just h7 and that's it nah there there's
no way to prevent queening
so after this a4 check king captures on
b4 was played instead
by 11 and now comes a5
uh starting to push that past pawn
rook to a6 attacking the bishop and now
bishop to c1 and now 11 will try to
harass that bishop
but it's easier said than done rook f6
check kink the g2
and now rook back to d6 with a6 now the
pass pawn will be pushed
rook to d1 attacking the bishop and
bishop to e3 now rook d3 again attacking
the bishop
bishop to c1 back rook d1 of course 11
very happy to repeat the position but
now bishop to h6
of course rajabo wants to push his pawns
to victory
uh rook to d6 attacking the bishop and
now even
a7 so giving up that bishop and notice
that it
doesn't help white to pin the rook here
because just the
c1 queen the bishop no longer guards the
queening square so you have to be
careful not to blunder the game away
like this
so after this rook to d6 move we have a7
uh and now uh there's not much you can
do here you can either play this and
give up the rook
or you can at least grab the bishop so
rook captures bishop was played
but now uh rajabov just brings a queen
into the game
and here uh queen uh c1 queen uh
11 also brings a queen into the game but
now a lot of moves here are possible
uh and the winning but one is just
crushing so for the last time feel free
to pause the video and
win this game for rajab while i give you
a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting the
easiest and quickest way to victory
and for those who just want to enjoy the
show it's uh rook
captures on b1 this comes with check so
you have to capture otherwise you lose
the queen
queen captures and now the very simple
queen to b8 or b7 check
just wins you the game king a3 queen
captures on b1 and that's of course
just it but of course the game didn't
last until then after rook captures on
b1
uh of course levin resigned and uh a
wonderful wonderful victory for
rajabov so this was what happened in
game two and
game three uh is where eleven really
needed a win
otherwise uh the game the match is over
so for those of you who still
uh haven't uh seen the results i'm gonna
spoil it now so
you know stop listening uh game three
ended in a draw
which means that rajab is the winner of
everything's masters 2020
and that he uh well that he just
obliterated
everyone he hasn't lost a single game in
the finals hasn't lost a single game in
the semi-finals
i was just uh really really remarkable
uh and even against the animation he
only he only lost i think
two games in quicker time format so it's
a really really
impressive performance and like he said
he he hoped that he will not
face magnus uh in the tournament uh but
dubois eliminated magnus so he he took
care of that but uh
it'd be it'd be pretty good to check out
the match uh
uh rajab versus magnus but we'll have to
uh wait for a different time to see that
uh so
really amazing stuff uh thank you all
for for watching i really hope you guys
enjoyed it
and that you've enjoyed the uh coverage
of the entire tournament we're gonna
check out what happened in the
semi-final
in the finals but in the match for the
third place between the nil lubovo and
maxine vashila grav tomorrow
uh but until then this is it from the
actual finals between rajab and aaron
so congratulations to rajab once again
and it's very good to see that he is
once again informed and this is uh
something very interesting i
heard him say in the interview everyone
always says that he retired from chess
and then he just came back five years
later but he said no
i kind of never retired i just started
uh losing against all top players so so
i just stopped playing for a while
but he didn't he said he didn't retire
he of course kept studying and kept
improving
and this what you see here is the result
uh so yeah once again uh thank you all
for watching uh i would like to thank
donald stanton donald ness jack giltrap
sai krishna song with
sana kayala and ryan needs for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day